as the world continues to mourn the
victims of the Orlando mass shooting ET
caught up with LGBT supporters on the
West Hollywood gay pride float on Sunday
with the most respect to the lives that
were lost and it's so sad the best way
to respect what happened last night i
think is to continue to show the
strength around the pride that everyone
has
barely famous stars Aaron and Sara
Foster stand in solidarity amid
America's deadliest shooting massacre
obviously the news this morning from
Orlando is weighing heavily on
everybody's minds I wonder your
reactions when you guys first heard the
news obviously you wake up to that news
and it's devastating I'm sorry to
interrupt you but it's just one more
reminder that gun control is not where
it needs to be we need to be taking
steps to completely eliminate access to
us to military weapons this is it's just
not okay in light of recent attacks the
Los Angeles area came together and
continue to celebrate LGBT rights you
can go two ways you can be afraid and
you can say I want to cancel and I want
to put myself in harm's way or you can
stand stronger and band together with
everyone and say that no matter what
happens we're still going to stay strong
and still show up and still support
everyone's ability and right to love
each other freely and not have to be in
fear
you